oh good evening or maybe I should say
Shalom given that introduction I'm a
little embarrassed to have my resume
read in light of the resume I'm about to
share but I suppose I should just start
by saying thank you all for being here
tonight I had the distinct honor of
introducing this evenings a WC speaker
mr. Peter Wallison a Peter J woloson is
the Arthur F Byrnes Fellow and financial
policy studies at the American
Enterprise Institute there he is also
co-director of AEI z-- program on
financial policy studies previously he
practiced banking corporate and
financial law at Gibson Dunn & Crutcher
in Washington DC and in New York mr.
woloson also served as general counsel
of the United States Treasury Department
during the regular administration a
graduate of Harvard College Harvard
College mr. woloson received his law
degree from Harvard Law School he
testifies frequently before Congress and
is a regular contributor to The Wall
Street Journal among many other
publications he is the editor co-editor
author and co-author of many and
numerous books including his most recent
work judicial fortitude the last chance
to reign in the administrative State so
please join me in giving a very warm
welcome to mr. Peter Wallison
[Applause]
that's a pleasure to be here see some
familiar faces out there I'm going to be
talking about the book which is the it's
called judicial fortitude the last
chance to reign in the administrative
state and it's actually very appropriate
for delivering at at Hillsdale because
it is all about Liberty and it's all
about democracy and and the the
government's operations I've spoken at
Hillsdale and have been impressed as
have been now with meeting Mason with a
student body there and what an
extraordinary place it really is I will
in my remarks I will talk about one of
the reasons that Hillsdale is does not
take government funds because the
government is rather a bully when you
are taking their funds and Hillsdale has
avoided that by supporting itself well
let me get started because this book
begins with this sentence it is not too
much to say that we risk losing our
democracy unless we can control the
eight the agencies of the administrative
state this is not the way most Americans
even many students of administrative law
think about the growing power of the
federal administrative agencies which
include incidentally cabinet agencies
like Treasury or HHS and regulatory
agencies such as the SEC or the EPA but
that is the real issue raised by the
extraordinary growth in the importance
of these agencies which many call
because of their power and a
pervasiveness in our society the
administrative state
for this reason the book is more a
political statement and a call to action
than a legal work and I think you'll see
why over 200 years ago the framers of
our Constitution designed what can best
be described as a Democratic Republic
Democratic comes from the fact that the
laws are made by an elected Congress and
Republic from the fact that the citizens
don't vote directly on the laws but only
for their representatives in Congress we
all know that this indirect democracy
structure was ratified by the people of
the states in 1788 and remains
essentially the same today perhaps more
important than the Constitution
structure is the fact that most
Americans believe they live in a
democracy
and thus that ultimately they have the
power to control the government's
activities and policies through their
votes in the book I cite a remarkable
2018 Monmouth poll in which Americans
said they were more interested in seeing
the issues fought out in the legislative
process this is actually a little hard
to believe but it's there and cited in
the book they're more interested in
seeing the entry the issues fought out
in the legislative process than in
whether the outcome that they would
prefer actually prevails this belief is
the source of the government's
legitimacy that is the moral authority
to demand obedience to its laws we
Americans voluntarily obey the laws
because we can participate in making
them by voting for Congress but as more
and more of the rules seem to be made by
unelected officials and here we're
getting to talk about the administrative
state there is a danger that the
government's legitimacy will be subject
to question we have seen this happen
elsewhere in 2016
a popular movement in Great Britain
called for a referendum on whether the
country should withdraw from the
European Union nickname brexit one of
this movements principal complaints was
that the British people were being
governed by a group in Brussels over
which they had no control Britain of
course is a democracy like ours and its
population is accustomed to believing
that the government will respond to its
wishes but despite the claims of many in
Britain's leadership that the departure
from the EU would be catastrophic for
the economy in Britain a majority of the
Britons voted to leave in June of 2016
we hear about this every day in the news
of course because they're having a lot
of difficulty with negotiating a
withdrawal this is an example though of
what happens when a government in this
case the European Union loses its
legitimacy those who think it can't
happen here that no substantial number
of people in the United States are
feeling disenfranchised have not really
taken on board the full meaning of the
Trump election in 2016 that vote has
been called a populist uprising and
certainly it was just like brexit but at
its source
like brexit was a growing sense among a
large portion of the American people
that the US government no longer
represents them or their priorities the
popular statement that President Trump
will drain the swamp in cops encapsulate
this idea the swamp and most conception
seems to include not only the lobbyists
cast but also the anonymous officials
who are responsible for rules that seem
to go beyond common sense if this trend
continues and it shows no sign of
abating it raises a brexit like question
of legitimacy for the United States the
challenge then is to develop a way to
limit the growth of the administrative
state so that it is no longer seen
as many seeit today as an out-of-control
government issuing rules and regulations
that reflect the views of the
bureaucracy in Washington and not those
of the American people there are
mechanisms to correct this the problem
arose because we have as I will explain
drifted from the framers design but as
we will see through a system of checks
and balances the framers ingenious
design also supplied a way for the
original structure to be restored the
Constitution of course creates a
government of separated powers under the
framers plan Congress has the sole power
to make the laws the president has the
sole power the president and the
executive branch has the sole power to
enforce the laws and the judiciary has
the province and duty to interpret the
meaning of the laws by separating the
legislative power from the executive
power by specifying that only Congress a
representative elected body had the
power to make the laws the framers hoped
to prevent both lawmaking and
enforcement from falling into the same
hands they had just secured their
independence in a world in which Kings
could both make laws and enforce them
and to the framers this was the source
of the tyranny they saw around them at
the time under the Constitution
accordingly apart from certain specified
powers provided to the president by the
Constitution itself neither the
president nor any agency of the
executive branch can act without the
authority of a law passed by Congress
logically then Congress cannot
constitutionally delegate to the
President or any agency of the executive
branch the lawmaking authority that the
Constitution reserved to that is vested
in Congress to do so would nullify the
purpose of the constitutional separation
of powers
the framers however recognized that the
Constitution was only a piece of
parliament a parchment at its base and
it's essential structure could be
compromised over time as the government
responded to the pressure of political
events one way to ensure long-term
stability was to create a system of
checks and balances so that each
government branch had some ability to
interfere with the actions of the others
for example Congress could enact a law
but the president could veto it the
president could make a treaty but the
Senate would have to approve it and
Congress alone could appropriate funds
for the executive branch and the
judiciary the check the checks and
balances were obviously intended to
create a basis for bargaining among the
branches as each could obstruct a
significant power of the others
underlying this strategy was the
assumption that each of the branches
would be jealous of its powers but there
are indications today and this is
fundamental to the argument in the book
there are indications today that this
idea was incorrect the modern Congress
has become an appendage of the President
and seems eager to hand over legislative
functions to the executive branch
especially when both are controlled by
the same political party
however the framers had inserted another
device into the constitutional system to
assure its survival an independent
judiciary whose members would have
lifetime appointments and thus could
resist major changes in the framers
design the courts then were to make sure
that Congress and the executive branch
stayed within their aside constitutional
roles that the judiciary has this Duty
was made clear by Alexander Hamilton in
fellers Federalist Papers 78 Federalist
Papers are a series of articles that the
framers wrote
in support of the Constitution to get
the people to ratify it there in that
paper Hamilton called the judiciary the
guardian of the Constitution and
explained why the Constitution gave the
judges lifetime appointments it's easy
to see he wrote that it would require
and I'm quoting here that it would
require an uncommon portion of fortitude
in the judges to do their duty as
faithful guardians of the Constitution
where the legislative invasions of it
had been instigated by the major voice
of the community this is the the
language is a little old-fashioned but
what he was saying is as guardian of the
guardians of the constitution the
judiciary was expected to step in and
preserve the separation of powers when
the elected branches responding to the
inevitable pressures of elective office
sought to change the way the framers
intended the government to operate to
provide the judiciary with the necessary
fortitude and again I stressed that word
because the name of the book the title
of the book is judicial fortitude I'll
use it again several more times to
provide the jury duty with the necessary
fortitude to challenge the elected
branches Hamilton argued judges had to
be appointed for life incidentally you
can imagine the debates that were going
on at the time that the Constitution was
was under consideration for ratification
people were saying well this is we're
supposed to have some control over this
government but you got all these judges
who have lifetime appointments why is
that
and Hamilton here was attempting to
answer that question which was coming up
a lot from potential voters to provide
the judiciary with the necessary
fortitude to challenge the elected
branches Hamilton argued judges had to
be appointed for life now
we have a problem like this today the
one I'm talking about with the
administrative state the question is
whether the judiciary really has the
fortitude to step in and act the
difficulty of preserving the separation
of powers should not be minimized not
least because it is extremely difficult
to define the line between legislation
which is exclusively the the province of
the Congress and administration or
execution of the laws which is the
exclusive province of the executive
branch perhaps because of its difficulty
as an intellectual matter and the
certain criticism to which the judiciary
would be subject if the law if the
courts entered this thicket the Supreme
Court has largely failed to discharge
this responsibility as the agencies of
the executive branch have increasingly
become rule makers and law givers for
our society in 2017 for example Congress
enacted 94 laws but administrative
agencies issued more than 3000 rules and
regulations that sounds like a lot in 1
year but the agencies have done the same
thing every year since 1993 for a total
of over 101,000 rules and regulations in
that quarter century period the annual
cost of complying with these regulations
has been estimated at 2 trillion dollars
which is more than the total amount of
revenue that the government gets each
year from corporate and private personal
income taxes to be sure there been many
cases where the judiciary has stepped in
to curb curb actions by Congress or the
president that in the courts view
exceeded their respective powers under
the Constitution the Supreme Court for
example has declared laws
unconstitutional as early this is laws
unconstitutional as early as 1803
validated an effort more recently by
President Truman to use his presidential
war powers to take over the steel
industry during wartime
but defending the separation of powers
is a far and very different problem from
these important and controversial steps
taking power from the executive and
restoring it to Congress would be a
massive change in the way that the
government operates today angering both
the president who would lose power and
Congress which has found that by
delegating its powers to the executive
branch it can conveniently avoid the
difficulties of legislating it would
also be very controversial with the left
which likes the decisions of the
administrative state a great deal and
doesn't worry about the fact that these
are not made democratically indeed far
from exercising fortitude until today
the Supreme Court has gone the other way
allowing the agencies of the executive
branch to take over more and more
authority of Congress and to make the
major decisions for society in other
words to engage in lawmaking how did we
come to this point for its first 150
years the system designed by the framers
functioned very well Congress as the
framers expected jealously guarded its
legislative authority during this period
and doled it out only sparingly to the
President or to the administrative
agencies but with the Great Depression
the election of Franklin D Roosevelt and
the advent of the New Deal
the relations between the judiciary and
the elected branches began to change
responding to FDR's requests Congress
voted to give extraordinary regulatory
and administrative power to the
presidency and the executive branch many
new agencies were created given broad
authority to
oversee and regulate major portions of
the economy these new relationships
raised in stark form the question of
whether Congress was delegating
excessive unconstitutionally legislative
power to the executive branch finally in
1935 for the first time the Supreme
Court nullified two laws enacted by
Congress on the ground that they were
unconstitutional delegations of
legislative power both decisions were
highly controversial as Hamilton foresaw
and were seen by many as the judiciary
interfering with the president's efforts
to combat the depression in the
elections that followed in the following
year that was 1936 FDR won a sweeping
victory and seemed to retaliate against
the court with a plan to increase the
number of associate justices from 8 to
15 this would have allowed him to
appoint seven new justices this court
packing plan as it was called was
unpopular with the public and was
eventually rejected by Congress but it
seemed to cau the Supreme Court which
has never again declared a law to be
unconstitutional because it delegated
legislative authority to the President
or to an administrative agency as
important beginning in 1937 the justices
of the 1935 Court began to retire
between 1937 and 1941 FDR was able to
appoint seven new justices and a chief
justice
all of whom supported his policy of
regulating the economy by creating new
agencies and providing them with broader
Authority the precedents for expanded
administrative authority established in
this period and afterward have
influenced decisions of the court to
this day
in 84 following out the idea for more
administrative power the Supreme Court
decided a case called Chevron versus
Natural Resources Resources Defense
Council which directed the lower federal
courts to defer to agencies
interpretations of their statutory
authority if those interpretations were
reasonable in terms of the policies that
Congress seemed to be enacting that
ruling gave a major boost to the growth
of the administrative state because it
enabled federal agencies to use in new
ways laws that had been enacted for
other purposes in the past in addition
with agencies assuming more powers
Congress found it convenient to enact
very general laws directing agencies to
achieve certain goals without Congress
having to really make the difficult and
controversial decisions that legislation
involves so the agencies were directed
for example to assure that our water is
clean and our air is pure but without
deciding who is to bear the cost whose
property is to be burdened with the
resulting restrictions these laws in
effect pass on to the agencies of the
executive branch the difficult decisions
imposing costs and taking away benefits
that in a democratic society should only
be made by Congress administrative
agencies then in many cases have been
able to supplant Congress as the
nation's lawmakers even though they are
headed by unelected officials with help
without the inherent power to decide
things for our society of course in the
in the ordinary case the role of an
administrative agency is to fill in the
details of a more general statute that
Congress might enact so for example if a
statute says that employers must pay
overtime to any employee who works more
than 8 hours in a day the agency will
define the words overtime
employee and day those are the kinds of
filling in of details that one might
think of for an administrative agency
but too frequently agencies go beyond
filling in the details and interpret the
language of their authorizing statutes
to cover things that Congress didn't
intend when they do this they are
clearly taking over the lawmaking role
of Congress there is no getting around
this as long as we have a system of
separated powers in which Congress is
supposed to make the laws and the
agencies of the executive branch are
only authorized to enforce the laws
Congress cannot delegate its legislative
authority to executive agencies
nor can agencies be allowed to interpret
the statutory authority they have been
given so that their authority extends
further than Congress actually intended
both steps would do with the framers
sought to prevent combined in one body
both legislative and executive power yet
this appears to be happening when under
the Chevron rule courts have to defer to
agencies interpretations of their own
powers in 1972 for example and here's
where I come to something that is
particularly relevant to Hillsdale
Congress enacted a series of amendments
to the laws governing the federal
government's financial support of
colleges and universities one provision
of the statute said no person in the
United States shall on the basis of sex
be excluded from participation in be
denied the benefits of or be subject to
discrimination under any educational
program or activity receiving federal
financial assistance this language which
Congress meant to prevent schools from
discriminating against women in such
matters as college admission curricula
and sports has been used was used
beginning in 1970
- by the Department of Education to
prescribe how colleges and universities
must react to sexual harassment between
students in other words a law that was
intended to ensure that women were given
the same educational opportunities by
schools was used for something entirely
different a law that covers how students
treat one another under its rules the
department has also prescribed how
schools must treat those who were
accused of sexual harassment including
the kind of trial that must be held and
the amount of evidence that is required
for a finding of harassment all of this
was spun out of a law that began as
nothing more than an effort to ensure
that women are not discriminated against
in the provision of a school's
educational resources there are many
other examples in judicial fortitude of
federal agencies going beyond their
authority under congressional statutes
but this is one reason that a school
like Hillsdale would stay out of this
process because it's not just the laws
relating to sexual harassment but other
things use of bathrooms and all of that
stuff that has been coming out of the
out of the government is based on this
1972 law and it's obvious that Congress
never intended it to cover something
like sexual harassment which wasn't even
a thought in people's minds in those
years and of course doesn't apply to the
activities of schools it applies only to
the activities of students there are
many other examples clearly when they
are going beyond their statutory
authority they are making laws and not
just enforcing them this is the crux of
the matter and the reason that there
have been more than 3,000 regulations in
every year with the courts allowing it
to happen the agencies of the
administrative state like the Department
of Education have been able to broaden
their authorities beyond what Congress
actually enacted the deference to
agencies interpretations of their
statutory powers authorized in the
Chevron case has contributed to this
problem but so has the fact that the
courts have never tried since 1935 to
define the line between legislation and
administration in other words what
decisions have to be made by Congress
and what is allowable to be for Congress
to delegate to administrative agencies
accordingly it is the failure of the
courts to make these difficult decisions
a failure if you will of judicial
fortitude that has enabled the agencies
of the administrative state to become
lawmakers instead of simply law
administrators as Hamilton pointed out
in Federalist 78 the members of the
judiciary were given life terms for a
reason in addition if nothing else
worked to preserve the separation of
powers the judiciary was to be the
failsafe mechanism with a separation of
powers and the Democratic structure of
the government now in the same kind of
jeopardy this appears to be the time for
the judiciary to intervene but
judiciary's role has got to be in some
respects limited it has no
constitutional authority to intervene in
the making of national policy and it
must adhere strictly to the principles
of judicial restraint in dealing with
laws enacted by Congress but preserving
the Constitution structure the framework
upon which our government rests is the
special responsibility of the judiciary
judicial restraint accordingly is not
applicable here the American people have
a right to expect that the Supreme Court
will step in to stop the drift of
lawmaking away from Congress and into
the hands of the administrative state
first that means that the Supreme Court
will have to modify or eliminate Chevron
deference this will reinstate judicial
review in which a court considers in the
first instance whether a challenged rule
or regulation is authorized by a statute
to be sure administrative use of the
scope of their authority are entitled to
respect but not deference the only fair
way to determine whether an agency's
view is correct is to have it assessed
by an objective court and an independent
court in addition the Supreme Court will
have to begin restoring the non
delegation doctrine which I mentioned
earlier the idea that the courts will
invalidate laws that delegate
legislative authority to the executive
branch the difficulty of this task
should not be underestimated but it is
clear that the separation of powers is
meaningless let me repeat that the
separation of powers is meaningless if
the courts do not attempt to define the
difference between legislative and
administrative actions and if the
separation of powers is meaningless so
is the protection of Liberty that the
framers sought to achieve by preventing
lawmaking and law enforcement from
falling into the same hands if the
courts follow the course I am
recommending and that's what the book
recommends Congress will be forced to
meet two different tests the statutes it
enacts will have to be specific enough
so that a reviewing court will be able
to determine how much authority Congress
has intended to provide to executive
branch agencies but the authority cannot
be broad so broad that it enables the
agency to assume exclusive legislative
power from Congress as a result Congress
will be forced to perform the vital role
of legislating deciding who benefits and
who is burdened by its policy
formulations and will not be able to
leave those decisions to administrative
agencies
this will prevent an eventual brexit
like loss of legitimacy for the US
government the good news from the
perspective of people with my views
about the administrative
is that with the confirmation of Neil
Gorsuch and Brett Kavanaugh in the last
two years to be associate justices of
the Supreme Court there are now five
members of the court who call themselves
constitutionalists and believe in the
importance of the separation of powers
this includes Chief Justice Roberts who
in a 2013 case both proposed to modify
Chevron and noted that it and I'm
quoting here it is the obligation of the
judiciary not only to confine itself to
its proper role but to ensure that the
other branches do so as well
this is a clear Restatement of
Hamilton's view of the judiciary as the
guardian of the Constitution and the
separation of powers there is no doubt
that these decisions about Chevron and
the separation of powers if they are
made will be controversial many groups
especially on the left like the policies
of the bureaucracies in Washington and
have no concerns that these decisions
are made by unelected officials for
example in October 2018 Eric Posner a
professor at Chicago Law School made
clear in a New York Times op-ed exactly
how the left will oppose any decision by
the new conservative court to modify
Chevron and implement a more limited
role for the administrative agencies the
real question he wrote and I'm quoting
is whether the Supreme Court will
determine will undermine I'm sorry the
Supreme Court won't undermine the system
of government that has protected the
public from abusive business practices
since the New Deal so there it is I mean
that's going to be the attack the
Supreme Court is eliminating the
protections of the public the issue of
whether there's Liberty here the issue
of whether we have a democracy is not
important it's whether the court is
going to be eliminating protections of
public against business thus explaining
why it is necessary to restore the full
separation of powers will be a legal
challenge for the court and a political
challenge for those who want to limit
the power of the administrative state in
the coming controversy the lodestar for
all of us must be that the framers
designed a democratic system in which
the people through an elected Congress
not unelected bureaucracies must make
the major decisions for society efforts
to keep the powers in the hands of the
administrative state are really efforts
to substitute the priorities of
government bureaucracies for the views
of the American people therefore even if
the American people agree with some of
the decisions of administrative agencies
as they surely will we will all have to
make sure that they understand the
American people understand this singular
fact that we cannot survive as a
democratic republic unless these
decisions by administrative agencies
have first been authorized by Congress
thanks very much
[Applause]
why do you think that federal judges
being given life tenure their salary
can't be cut everybody has to stand up
when they come in the room why have they
been such cowards over the years well
there were a lot of reasons but I think
the one that most particularly I wrote
about in the book is what happened with
the court packing plan and that is that
the Roosevelt then proposed to add seven
new justices to the Supreme Court I
think that shocked the court because
they realized that the court was
suddenly thrown into this political
environment where the appointment of a
justice was going to be something that
the President did in order to get his
policies adopted and I think they they
realized then that they could get
themselves into trouble if they stepped
too far so I it's not so much all of the
judges or even a majority of the judges
it's the Supreme Court in my view that
has put us in this position because
they're the ones who actually make the
decisions that all the other judges
follow and my my communications over the
years with judges many of whom are
conservatives but my communications with
them indicate that they they've been
unhappy with some of the decisions from
the Supreme Court but feel that they
have to follow those rules because it is
the Supreme Court and that's the system
that works the Supreme Court makes the
decision and all the judges follow it
out so I'm not sure that judges are
weaklings or unable to exercise
fortitude but more question of the
Supreme Court trying to stay out of
trouble with the political system and
I'm the book says you've got to stop
doing that you have to start acting as
guardians of the Constitution which is
what the framers expected you to do
maybe we can call them to account that
way if no other do I call on people or
what
no all right standing in the back is
that close to the microphone if your
wish comes true and we get juicers on
the Supreme Court that actually tried to
enact what you're proposing are there
any guarantees today that would prevent
a new packing plan of the court to be
enacted and to intimidate them again
that of course is the problem and right
now if you've been reading these things
in the newspaper the left is proposing a
new court packing plan to take over the
court the the control of the Supreme
Court now it hasn't it hasn't gotten a
lot of publicity up to now but it will
certainly get a lot of publicity during
the coming campaign and even though I
think the American people probably would
not approve this as they didn't in 1937
nevertheless it could spook the Supreme
Court well that when they read my book
they will see that the framers expected
them to act in a particular way this is
not something that is well-known
actually I have done a lot of reading in
this area and Alexander Hamilton's
Federalist 78 isn't has not been quoted
anywhere the way I have quoted it in
this book so this does put put on the
table whether the court is going to act
as a guardian of the Constitution as
Hamilton said the framers expected I
don't know whether it'll work but it's
better than nothing
other cases in the pipeline that would
bring Chevron into into a question yes
this one there is one right now the
court took a case called Chi so reverses
and Wilke which involves deference to an
administrative agency's interpretation
of its own regulations that's called our
deference aue our deference I think I
see the lawyers nodding in here but the
in our deference the Court has always
held that administrative agencies can
interpret their own regulations any way
they want
once it's their regulation they can do
anything they want but the court has now
beginning to recognize that the
administrative agency can do a
tremendous amount of damage by changing
the interpretation of its regulations as
it did in this particular case kaizo
versus Wilkie so they have said they
will now review our deference a yu-er
deference if they decide as I believe
they will that our deference is no
longer going to be the the position of
the courts it will be an immediate
signal that they are going now to look
at Chevron and there are lots and lots
of cases involving Chevron every every
term of the court has at least one case
where Chevron can be introduced and
discussed so I don't think there'll be
any difficulty in getting a case before
the court and I think we will ultimately
have a decision in that direction but
again I want to say this it's very
important that the court understand that
there is support for the position that
they take if they are going to modify
Chevron because there will be huge
blowback from the left of the kind I'd
read to you and so conservatives have to
get out there and start talking about
the fact that it's important that these
decisions be made so that the Supreme
Court believes that the American people
are actually or at least a substantial
portion of the American people are with
them on this and we have to start doing
that before the decisions come down
because the decisions may not come down
the way we want them if the Chief
Justice decides that he doesn't want the
court to get into trouble again as they
did in 1935 so let's that's the lesson
we all have to take from this yes sir
I'm recognizing that it would be another
big hurdle do you think that term
limiting the judiciary would have a
positive or negative impact on
recommending well I'm I'm generally in
favor of lifetime appointments for
judges for just the reason that we're
talking about they haven't used that
lifetime appointment as they should but
it's never too late for them to
recognize why they have lifetime
appointments and to stand up to the
kinds of criticism that they would get
if they actually changed Chevron or or
instituted the non delegation doctrine
which is equally maybe even more
important so I don't think we want to
make them term-limited because we would
have fights of the kind that we have now
over the appointment of every judge at
every level when we have a Kavanagh like
fight over the Supreme Court we would
start having them at district courts and
at at appellate courts because every
judge would be responding to the
political party that nominated him or
her and that would put us in a very bad
position I think we think that we would
it would be hard to get objective
rulings from judges anymore at least
though is that we would consider
objective so I think we ought to keep it
the way it is let judges
serve out a life term as long as they
want but then do their duty as they have
been required to do by the framers yes
sir yeah well that's that that is the
big problem I cannot do that
I don't think anyone can do that
and that's because the court the Supreme
Court in particular has for many many
years 200 years I said not tried to
define that line now courts do this all
the time I mean what is assert what is
an allowable search and seizure what
what is what is interstate commerce what
is a void void for vagueness which are
all terms that come up all the time in
court cases and the courts have over the
years pronounced what these things how
you define these things these things
it's called a jurisprudence so there
should be a jurisprudence of non
delegation where the court looks or all
the courts but certainly the supreme
court looks at a case that has come
before them and they say this is a case
where legislative authority has been
delegated that establishes a mark and
then there will be more marks and more
marks until it becomes pretty clear just
like it is in search and seizure when a
delegation has occurred I might say that
there is a case now before the Supreme
Court that was argued on October 2 we
have no decision yet could come any day
could come tomorrow as a matter of fact
but that decision the the Gundy case is
a very very narrow little case where the
question is whether someone is subject
to
a law that was passed at the state level
but also then later at the federal level
and the Congress did not say whether
people who had been convicted under the
law at the state level are also subject
to the federal law of disclosure and so
forth about their crime and what
Congress did was they gave it to the
Attorney General and they said you
decide now is that a delegation of
legislative authority shouldn't Congress
have made that decision how can they
hand it to the Attorney General that was
argued before the Supreme Court on
October 2 we'll have a decision but it's
so narrow that it might be exactly the
place where the court should be starting
they should start with something really
small one person who is who is who felt
he was Mis mishandled by a delegation of
legislative authority but once you do
that you're establishing a principle and
that principle then gets elucidated and
and and prayed over and and discussed
until you have a jurisprudence and
that's where we should be in ten or
fifteen years I fail to fully understand
the logic of the blowback argument that
you're talking about
let's say a court strikes down an
example of administrative rulemaking
based on the non delegation doctrine the
court isn't isn't rejecting the
protections that may be the subject of
that rulemaking the court is simply
saying that those protections need to be
part of a statute enacted by Congress
right if those protections are
compelling why wouldn't want to expect
Congress to do exactly that to write a
statute that expressly includes those
protections that's fine of course that's
good Congress should write a statute
that includes those protections examine
is that the people who favor those
protections have had it very easy they
haven't had to have a Congress passed
the law they've gotten an administrative
agency to do which is a lot easier
to do so that if you if you agree with
those protections that's one thing if
you disagree then you're on the wrong
side of the issue so what we want is we
want Congress to be told once the court
has said well this court this agency
went too far didn't have the authority
there would be a lot of opposition to
that decision and let's assume it's made
by the Supreme Court be a lot of
opposition to that that decision but the
next thing that would happen is that a
whole lot of people who liked the
administrative rule will run to Congress
and say pass this law and that's the way
it ought to work right that's what we
have a Congress for right okay so we
agree we agree okay I like that part yes
sir in the back
not enough judges I do think it is the
result and the book goes into this in
some detail it is the result of an idea
that developed in in the United States
in in the Progressive Era between about
1880 and 1920 when the thought was that
all our problems should be handled
not through the constitutional structure
that exists these are ideas that I'm
talking about here that came mostly from
Woodrow Wilson not through the
constitutional structure that exists but
because we should have more people in
positions of regulatory power to handle
all of these problems and these people
should be intelligent disinterested well
well credentialed and and fair and
objective people and they should be
making these decisions for the American
people
if you read Woodrow Wilson this is what
he wanted to do he wanted to change the
constitution so that the administrative
agencies would have that power what
happened then is that when the when FDR
came into office and there was a
depression that he had to address they
went back to this idea that had been
popular 40 50 60 years before for the
the economy to be regulated the American
system to be regulated by these experts
and that's how it that's how this idea
began and it gradually grew over time to
the point where we now have this
gigantic administrative state which
doesn't do what its its supporters
during the Roosevelt era thought it
would do and that is manage the economy
with in a way that everyone would be
happy with it turns out that it is a
monster that has taken over a lot of the
power that should have been exercised
and should be exercised through Congress
I'm sorry of course absolutely you you
have to Congress has to make the
decision that someone has the power to
approve drugs and they have to provide
some standards for when drugs would be
approved and when they wouldn't be
approved then under after that point the
then you can give the authority to an
administrative agency which would do it
under the standards that Congress has
laid down but if Congress were to say we
know they're going to be a lot of drugs
around so you approve them that's that's
not the way that and an organized
government or to be operating Congress
should be deciding the circumstances
under which drugs are approved or not
approved and that's the problem is that
that hasn't been happening we have time
for one last question one last question
well right there know about this young
lawyer right here Mason so we've talked
a lot about how Congress has sort of
usurped their authority and stepped
outside their bounds by delegating their
authority to the administrative branch
now if they're delegating their
authority to the executive then that
means the executive to some extent is
obviously outside its scope and I think
a lot of people probably including
yourself would agree that the judiciary
as well like we seem to be living this
age of sort of judicial activism and
where people accuse the judiciary of
legislating from the bench so if it's
really true that we have all three
branches of government all three outside
of their legitimate scope do you have
any real hope that we can get back to
the original structure well it is
certainly true that the judiciary has
gone beyond its original scope in some
ways one of the reasons for that is that
Congress has not been engaged they do
not act on
things that they should act on and as a
result of that people go to the courts
to try to get solutions and the courts
have been all too willing to do that
what I'm talking about is a a structure
in which the courts agree that they are
not supposed to be involved in making
policies for the country and that a
people are coming to the courts to do
that they should be told we this is not
our business go to Congress and to the
extent that they do that we will have
the kind of government the kind of
system that is a democratic system that
most people can agree with but yes it is
a problem if courts given a lot of
courts take a lot of power and begin to
use that power and are drunk with the
power that they have obtained for
themselves we have a another kind of
problem but that's not the problem that
I see I see a problem of loss of our
democracy loss of the structure that the
framers had in mind caused largely by
the fact that Congress is not doing what
it should be doing and leaving this to
an unelected bureaucracy everyone please
join me in thanking mr. Wallace